- You saw him yesterday
in Pennsylvania
where they managed to let
him out of the basement
basically so they
could cut an add
to make it look like
he's actually out there.
You know, it's all
from the same shot
but Joe Biden was out of
his basement miraculously
for a few minutes but
he forgets where he is.
He forgets his wife
from his sister.
He forgets the office
he's running for.
He's looking at
notes, you see him.
I mean, he literally
read the subtext
of the teleprompter stuff.
It looks like he's trying
to give an organic interview
when he's reading the bullet
points on a teleprompter
because he can't remember them.
And now you compare that with,
okay, two brain aneurysms
is probably an issue,
nothing to see here, folks.
I mean, the cause and
effect is so flagrant
and it would be sad, Dave,
if it wasn't so scary
for our country.
(bright upbeat music)
- All right people,
this is "The Rubin Report"
with a brand new set
and the same old host.
I'm back on the grid
and we're jumping right
back into the fray.
Joining me today is the
executive vice president
of Development and Acquisitions
at the Trump Organization
and author of the new
book, "Liberal Privilege",
Donald Trump Jr, welcome
back to "The Rubin Report".
- Good to be with you, Dave.
- That is some serious
branding behind you right now.
I mean, you guys are
not messing around, man.
- I'll always be branding,
you know the deal.
I mean, the last time
I was on with you,
we both had a book coming
out at the same time.
So there was a little bit of
jostling for dominance there.
So, this time I figured I'm
by myself so I can go all out.
- All right, well, that's
exactly where we're gonna start
because we were
jostling for dominance
and much to the chagrin
of the fine people
at "The New York Times".
At the top of your new book,
"Liberal Privilege", it
says, "Donald Trump jr,
number one, 'New York
Times' bestselling author."
Are you shocked that
they allowed your
last book "Triggered"
not only to make the list,
I mean, I made the
list too, just saying
but they let you be number one.
And when I say let
it's because everyone knows
the whole thing is made up.
- Yeah, I really was.
I sort of...
One of the dreams of
last year would have been
to just be a fly on the
wall as they had to do it.
But when I looked
into the real...
and they tried doing
the asterick thing
and they were like,
"Well, he had some bulk sales,"
the RNC bought like
4,000 copies of the book.
Now they resold them.
So it's still an
individual sale,
but they also marked
them up and resold them.
They actually made a net
$900,000 profit to the RNC
for themselves, net, right?
That's a big deal.
So it's still an
individual sales,
but they said, "Well, asterick
because of bulk sales."
I go, "But, well, okay.
If I sold 75,000 copies in that
sort of the way they do it,
in that week one, right?
75,000 is a huge number.
I was on par with Elton
John the week before.
So it was a big number.
I said, "Fine, take that
number totally out of it.
And I'm at 71."
I go, "Well, what
was number two?"
And they go, "Well, this book,"
I go, "How many did they sell?"
Like 28,000.
I go, "So I'm 2.5 times
bigger than number two.
Even if you take out the quote
unquote bulk sales from it."
So I don't think they
had much of a choice,
but they must have been really,
really disappointed
about that one.
- Yeah.
I guess there's a little liberal
privilege involved in that
because if you were a
liberal in this case
writing a book, then it
would have been easier,
to just put you on the
list without the sales.
But basically you sold so
many, they couldn't stop you.
So that's actually
an interesting place
to start because...
so this is your second
book now within a year,
which ain't easy.
So I wanna talk
to you about that,
but first off you chose to
self-publish this thing.
And I sense that this
is not just about,
you couldn't find
a publishing house.
I sense you're up to something
a little bigger than that.
- Yeah.
I mean, we sold over 400,000
copies of "Triggered",
you know, the last time.
So, I actually turned
down a much better deal
than my first deal
from a publisher,
but I'm sure you've
heard the same thing.
I mean, a lot of people
who are writing now
conservative books,
you know, I've been
with a couple of them,
they're my friends, some of
them have done just good books.
Some of them have done literal,
"New York times" bestsellers.
And they show me
the text messages
that they get from
their publishers.
"Hey, yeah, we don't want
you talking about this."
And I'm doing...
These aren't guys
that are pushing like
cue and on nonsense
or anything like that.
They're not pushing
fringe conservatism.
They're pushing
mainstream conservatism
and basically they're
being threatened
with part of their
livelihoods for just taking
what would be a moderate
conservative stance,
the publisher, you know,
"We're not gonna
publish your book,
if you comment on
this person's article
or retweet this individual,
or if you make this
kind of commentary
or you're getting
a little too hot."
So, you know, honestly,
I had no intention of
writing another book.
It was the one sort of
unintended consequence
of the lockdown was I'm at home,
I couldn't go to work,
you couldn't do anything.
I'm at home and I started
looking at the guy
we're supposed to
be running against.
And you know, I'm seeing
the media portray him
as this blank slate, Democrat,
you know, great history,
whatever I'm like, "Well,
let's see some details."
And when I started looking,
I was like, "Oh my God,
someone has to write this down,"
because it feels like it's me
versus the entire
mainstream media complex.
I mean, there is so
much about Joe Biden,
whether it's just bad decisions,
terrible decisions on trade,
terrible decisions on
race, policy stuff.
That's a disaster,
you know, things that
went on with his family,
the graph that it's not just
Hunter and the shade there,
but the brother and the sister.
I'm like, "Man, if we were
Joe Biden, with that record,
this would be global news,
but the media has just
totally abdicated their
responsibility to look into it."
So I started writing
all these things out.
I go, "There's a book here.
Someone has to put it out there.
Someone has to be, you know,
the oppo research
guy that the media...
You know, it's
sort of their job,
but they're refusing to do it
because they're no
longer journalists.
They're just activists.
They are left-wing activists.
And they refuse to talk about
so many of these issues.
So I started doing it and
I said, "You know what?
I don't want to be
beholden to a publisher."
Even if I turned
down a good offer.
It's like, you know,
that doesn't matter to me.
This story has to be told
and I don't want them saying,
"Yeah, you know what?
We're gonna delay until
after the election,"
or, "We have the power
to not put it out there."
I just said, "You know what?
I'm gonna take a chance and
literally do it on my own."
It was pretty amazing.
I guess on Monday
I was, you know,
number one nonfiction on Amazon,
but even more interestingly,
I made it available
on my website
cause you know, so many of
our conservative friends,
they don't wanna give money
to big tech and stuff like that.
So just on DonJr.com simply
like literally a buddy
of my found this.
He's like, "You know
that's available.
I got it for almost
nothing, I was amazing."
You know, we're moving
like about, you know,
40% of the volume that
I'm moving on Amazon
just on this little website
that we put together
because people would
rather just go direct,
than give money to
big tech on our side.
So it's doing really well.
But my biggest thing
is just making sure
that message gets out there,
that people, you
know, have a chance
and there's literally
560 citations in there
pointing to all of these things.
So no one can say
it's fake news.
No one can say no, no, no,
Joe Biden didn't
actually do that.
I mean, Joe Biden was for the
wall before he was against it.
He was pro-life before
he was against it.
He's beholden to
the radical left.
He supported NAFTA, TPP.
China's permanent status on
the World Trade Organization
that destroyed more American
jobs and the middle class
and the manufacturing
sector than anyone.
But now magically,
he's gonna be the savior
of the middle class.
I mean, you can't
make this crap up.
- All right.
So I read about half
the book this morning
and you just laid out a lot of
the arguments that you made.
And when I was looking at it,
I was thinking, you know,
the alternate title basically
for this book could have
been double standards, right?
Cause that's really what
you're saying in this book
that if my family
did these things,
this is how the media
would have portrayed it.
If my dad had made
these decisions,
this is what would happen.
And if I had gotten the benefits
that say Hunter
Biden had gotten,
this is how the media
would have dealt it.
I've said a lot of people
as I've gotten more comfortable,
let's say with your dad,
a lot of people will say to me,
"Well, I don't get it, Dave,
how could you support Trump?
How come you don't
think he's the devil,"
all of that kinda stuff.
And what I always say is,
"Well, he understood the media
more than anything else,"
that it wasn't just
Republicans versus Democrats.
It was Republicans versus
Democrats plus the media.
That to me seems to be a huge
thrust of what this book is.
Does it all boil down to the
double standards thing for you?
- Yeah, I mean,
yes and more right.
I mean, cause it's not
just a double standard,
it's just flagrant mistakes.
I mean, if you just look at
what's going on today that,
there was another
fake report, you know,
Donald Trump's suffered
a mini strokes,
and he had to be
treated at Walter Reed.
Now the doctors at Walter
Reed said, "This is nonsense.
It's untrue,"
but the media won't even
talk about Joe Biden
who's literally had
two brain surgeries
for literally brain aneurysms.
He had explosions in his brain.
Now, if you ask a
doctor about that,
what are the chances
that you could be a
hundred percent normal
after one brain surgery
after an aneurysm,
they'd say "Very little,"
how about two almost
impossible to be normal.
Now you take that with
Joe Biden's daily, daily
you saw yesterday
in Pennsylvania
where they managed to let
them out of the basement
basically so they
could cut an ad
to make it look like
he's actually out there.
You know, it's all
from the same shot,
but you know, Joe Biden was out
of his basement miraculously
for a few minutes, but
he forgets where he is.
He forgets his wife
from his sister.
He forgets the office
he's running for.
He's looking at
notes, you see him.
I mean, he literally
read the subtext
of the teleprompter stuff.
It looks like he's trying
to give an organic interview
but he's reading the bullet
points on a teleprompter
because he can't remember them.
And now you compare that with,
okay, two brain aneurysms.
It's probably an issue,
nothing to see here, folks.
I mean, the cause and
effect is so flagrant
and it would be sad, Dave,
if it wasn't so scary
for our country.
Joe Biden is basically, he's
camouflage for the far left.
They can try that...
The media will spend
billions trying to sell him
to middle America.
It's moderate Joe, moderate Joe.
But you know, you're not a
moderate with Kamala as your VP.
You're not a moderate with Beto,
hell yeah I'll take your AR
15 O'Rourke as your guns are.
You're sure as
heck not a moderate
with the Bernie Sanders
joint unity platform,
which is like a combination
of like the new age
communist manifesto
with the green new
deal blended into one.
And again, the media
won't talk about that.
So when you talk about,
you know, double standard,
it's not even that because
the playing field is so uneven
with a mainstream
media that's what,
96% negative against
Donald Trump?
I mean, that's a lot
of ground to overcome.
They won't talk about
the good things.
You saw...
Well, you may have been off
the grid when this happened,
but they got a peace deal
done in the Middle East.
- [Dave] I was just
gonna bring it up yeah.
- I mean, this is the Holy
grail of geopolitical politics,
hasn't been done in a
quarter of a century.
They spent more time last week
fact-checking my
three-year-old nephew,
if in fact he did build a lego
White House for my father.
Now there's a picture of it,
but they spend more
time talking about that
because Ivanka
mentioned in her speech,
attacking a
three-year-old though.
I mean, you know, Nick Sandmann
at 16, they destroy him.
I figured, okay, they wouldn't
go much lower than that,
but now they're going to a
three-year-old to attack him.
But the average
American has no idea
we signed a peace deal
in the Middle East
and you know, that's the
insanity we're up against.
So that's why this book,
it's not just for, you know,
people on the right it's
for people in the middle
who are undecided because
if you're undecided
and you're sort of
going 50 50 either way,
imagine you actually knew about
Joe Biden and his policies.
Imagine you actually heard about
the Trump Administration
successes,
neither of which you've
been made aware of.
That's what this book is,
it's designed to inform.
And again, it's more for
the people in the middle
that are unsure than
it is anything else
because someone had
to step up and do it.
- So in the chapter about
the Biden health stuff,
where you talk about
the brain aneurysms
and everything else and
you refer to Obama's doctor
and a bunch of other
medical professionals in it,
and you actually go out of
your way to make a point
that you're not
trying to mock the guy
and you have sympathy
for this kinda stuff.
Like you're not being a dick
about it, you're really not.
- Yeah.
- One thing that you sort
of hint at is basically,
and you sorta
implied this already,
that he's just kind of
a puppet for something.
What do you really
think that thing is.
Like is it the party apparatus?
Like who really is in charge
of the DNC at this point?
- Well, I think it's
the radical left.
I mean, you saw that
if you watch the DNC,
I don't know if you came out
of hiding it from that one.
If you didn't--
- I'm catching up,
catching up now.
- It'll save you a lot of grief.
Cause if you watch
that, you know,
you'd think that America was
the most oppressive regime ever
created in the world and
that it's a terrible place.
And you know, again, I
watched for five days,
not one person mentioned
the looting, the rioting,
the violence going,
not one at the DNC,
they had a week instead they
painted this picture of,
you know, America
is a terrible place.
If you like anything about it,
you're a terrible human being.
And you know, that's the thing
I wasn't trying to make light
of dementia or Alzheimer's.
I mean, we all know
people affected by it.
The difference is those
people can have a great life.
They can be great parents
and grandparents and have...
We're not gonna give
them the nuclear football
we're gonna just pretend
that didn't happen and say,
"Congratulations, here's the
largest economy in the world.
Here's the nuclear football."
I mean, if Joe Biden needs
notes to talk to a reporter,
that's literally trying
to love him softballs.
How is he gonna compete against
China and Russia and Iran?
Like he can't remember
where he is, I mean.
So, you know, it's either insane
or it's a cloak and
dagger type of thing
where they cover your eyes,
they pretend it's
moderate Joe from Scranton
of which he's not.
I mean, he's not
blue-collar Joe.
He got his first elected
official office in DC
when he was in his twenties,
like he's never had
a blue-collar job,
but you know, he's
curated this sort of lie
to market himself as this way.
So the radical left,
who's actually making
all the decisions.
Again, his platform
on his website is
Bernie Sanders' right?
His VP is Kamala Harris,
who's literally left
of Bernie Sanders in terms of
voting record in the Senate.
Like, do you think Joe
Biden's gonna be able
to stand up to them if they're
pushing for certain things?
No, but the media can use
him as camo, you know,
to sell to Middle America.
No, no, no, it's not
gonna be that radical.
It's not gonna be that bad.
But all you have to do
is look at his platform.
I mean, $4 trillion tax
hike to middle class America
does give free
healthcare to illegals.
Free education to illegals.
Free lawyers for the other ones
that will start
flooding our country.
Like who's that gonna hurt?
Probably not me.
It's gonna hurt our lowest
income earners, right?
Who's not gonna hurt?
How about you in a public school
that you have the privilege of
having to pay for yet again,
right?
You don't get free healthcare.
You don't get free
education for your kids,
certainly not
college or anything,
but you have the privilege
of paying for illegals
to get those benefits because
it creates Democrat voters.
I mean, think about
how insane that is.
It's not like our systems
have all this excess capacity
that they can handle it.
I mean, they're
already overworked.
Our medical system is
already overstressed,
our education system,
honestly our public education
system is a disaster.
It's 28th in the world.
spending more money per child
than any country in the world.
It's still 28th.
I mean, there are literally
third world countries
that are beating
us in education.
And the teachers
union is really sure
they don't wanna go back
to do in-person learning,
but they also don't
wanna do online learning.
Also part of their platform
since you've been gone
is they want to support
BLM and defund the police.
What does that have to do
with educating our children?
These are the radicals that
we're gonna be in charge,
and if you just
look at Joe Biden,
you see the way he has to
be carried off the stage
after he gives a
speech or, you know,
I say speech loosely
because you know,
the hardest job in America
is being his sign
language interpreter
cause no one knows what
the hell is going on.
- That poor guy.
- But that's what
I'm saying, it's sad.
But it would be sad if it
wasn't more scary for America.
- Yeah, All right.
You gave me a lot there so--
- [Donald Trump Jr] Sorry.
- Let's talk, no,
no, that's good.
So let's just do the Kamala
thing here for a minute
because we're you guys,
when I say you guys,
the Trump Organization,
the campaign, your dad,
what was the feeling when it
came out that it was Kamala
because on one hand I think
she's probably not as full
say communist, Marxist,
whatever that Bernie thing is.
But as you just pointed out,
her voting record
is pretty far left
and she's an
authoritarian, you know.
She did that line.
That line that I keep
bringing up in the debate
where they asked
Biden, you know,
"Will you do an executive
action on guns?"
And he said, "Well,
anything I would do
would have to be
constitutional,"
which of course is
the right answer.
And she looked at him
and laughed in his face.
And now this is the
person who is now his VP.
How did you guys feel
about the choice?
- Listen, I sort of thought,
I think it's a great thing,
right?
Cause you know
where her record is.
I mean, she's literally left
of Bernie in voting record.
She doesn't care about
those sorts of things.
As you've said,
so she's also so disingenuous.
She's just, you know, you
see that she's a phony.
And so it's just been pure
ambition for her whole life.
And you know, that's
not a terrible trait,
but it is when you basically
sell out all of your principals
to get there.
So for us, I think it's
actually a great choice,
but the media also
agrees because the
media also wanted her
to be number one,
that's who they were pushing
for, for a moment, number one.
Now she's terrible in the
stage, she's not so warm.
She's just terrible
candidate really.
But for us, I love it
because everyone believes
she's the one that's
gonna be in charge.
You know, it's
sort of, you know,
Joe Biden picking
her after she...
Now I got fact-checked for this.
They told me that I was...
They threw me off
Instagram for this one
because I said she
called him a racist
and she said to believe his
sexual assault accusers.
Cause again, remember when
someone accuses Joe Biden,
even though there's
corroborating
evidence much more so
that doesn't count only
those who accused Trump
of something with no evidence,
with no corroboration,
with all nonsense, you
know, that's to be believed.
But when it happens to Joe
Biden from a Senate staffer,
no, no, no nothing to see here.
But she did those
things and you saw her
absolutely demolish him
on the debate stage,
as it related to his racial
decision and his history.
Then I get into that
in the book a lot,
but I said, "When she
called him a racist.
And she said to believe his
sexual assault accusers."
So of course it
gets fact-checked.
Well she didn't
call him a racist,
I go, "What do you mean?"
They go, "Well, she didn't
say the words racist."
I go, "Yeah but she went
on a five-minute diatribe
about how he supported busing,
how he partied with
segregation, it's how he did,"
I mean, she did
literally everything,
but no reasonable person
in the world would assume
that she meant
anything other than.
Yeah, I think Joe
Biden's a racist,
but they can fact-check
you as false.
You know, they don't seem
to fact-check Joe Biden
in Pennsylvania yesterday
or the day before,
when he says, "I'm
not against fracking."
I'm like, "Well, here's you
on that same debate stage Joe
saying that you'd
eliminate fossil fuels.
That you said no new fracking.
Here's you talking
to another woman
saying we're gonna
eliminate it all."
I mean, there's 50 clips of him
saying exactly the opposite,
but because fracking is an
important issue in Pennsylvania,
that is a swing state.
The media will literally
run with the lie there
where it's more of
a sensitive issue.
They'll run with
exactly the opposite
and pretend as though
both of them are true,
just depending on who
they're selling to.
You know, they're
not fact-checking.
This is an egregious lie.
There's tape all over the place.
Not one fact-check
called him out on it.
Not one social media site
took him down for dishonesty.
They let him run the
clip as though it's true.
It's on his platform, just
go look at his website.
So again, part of the whole
thing that's liberal privilege
and you can have the
best of all worlds.
It doesn't matter what the
truth is, it doesn't matter.
We are going to sell
to the American public,
whatever it is that
they wanna hear
to be able to effectuate
the change that they want,
which is to put
Joe Biden in office
or whoever his puppet
masters really are.
- So is the best
example of that,
the exact video that Biden
launched his campaign with,
which was the
Charlottesville video?
And he is basically saying
your dad is supporting white
supremacist when, of course,
and no matter how many
times we talk about this,
it never makes it
to mainstream media.
The sentence before
your dad said,
"Fine people on both sides."
And of course what he meant
was of the statue debate,
completely condemned the KKK
and the white supremacists
and the Neo-Nazis and all those.
But the media ran cover
for Biden on that.
So in Biden's mind or
whatever's left of it,
he was just like, "All right,
well, I can just keep going
and lie,"
- And why not?
Hey, why not run with it?
I mean, they'll do
whatever it takes to win.
It's no problem, right?
That's what they're gonna do.
And by the way, they
brought that up at the DNC
multiple times as though
literally, you're right,
the first sentence led up to it.
So it was clear before it
wasn't like he made a mistake
and recovered.
It was very clear to begin with.
They play one
portion of the clip
and then they forget about the
second sentence, which was,
"And of course I'm condemning
the white supremacists
and the crazy people
that were there
because it wasn't all that,"
but they run with it as
though it's the gospel.
I mean, it's the same
thing in the media.
They're still running Dave
with Russia collusion.
There's still pretending
like that's a real thing.
Notice how no one
has any interest
in like looking into
Comey and the FBI
and Obama and Biden
himself unmasking us.
It's the first time we've
had a non peaceful transition
of power, a great, great,
great American tradition
for 240 something years,
nothing to see here, folks.
Now it was a big
deal for three years
when they thought it
worked the other way,
when it worked against Trump,
when they could do that,
I mean you've see the
testimony of these clowns.
I mean, under oath, they'd
say X on CNN later that day,
they say exactly the opposite
because no one's gonna
hold them accountable.
They know it's not true because
they're literally under oath
saying the opposite,
but guess what?
We get a CNN job.
How about, you know, the
Columbians and the McCabes,
these guys lied to Congress.
Oh, well, you know,
it's really bad,
you shouldn't lie to Congress,
but nothing to see here.
I'd be in jail if
I lied to Congress,
they get paid big bucks to
then be a CNN contributor.
I mean, they're
rewarded for treason.
They're awarded for
lying to the country
and to the American people.
That's sort of what
we're up against.
And again, that's why
I took it upon myself
to do this book when I
had no intention to do it
because I've been a part of it.
You know, if you didn't
believe in the deep state,
if you didn't believe in sort
of these big government things
prior to 2016, you
know what I get it.
If you don't now, if you
think that these people
are truly just trying
to represent you,
and they're not just
taking care of themselves,
you're out of your mind.
Look at what my father
has tried to do.
You know, pulling troops
out of Afghanistan,
ending these never ending wars
that our own generals
can't even tell us
why we're there anymore.
They start leaking
opposition research.
Trump is getting
soft on Russia, what?
There's more
sanctions on Russia,
than any administration
in American history,
but they do that because they
wanna stay in endless wars
because they don't care
about sending nice kids
from Middle America to go
lose life and limb abroad
so they can keep the military
industrial complex going.
And that's not just Democrats,
that they're a big part of it,
but it's also the neo-cons
and sort of the never
Trump Republicans
that hate that he's
getting it out.
You know why?
Because they wanna be
on the board of Raytheon
for $500,000 a year.
They'll do whatever it takes.
They'll get their board
seat, they'll do that.
All their friends get rich,
sending our kids to die
for something that we don't
even know why we're there.
And it never ends.
Trump tries to pull
out of these things
and you literally have
people in Congress
trying to literally
stop him from doing it.
And it's so obvious.
And yet again, nothing
to see here folks.
- Yeah, no, it's like,
you've suddenly got the never
war left sort of pro war
because Trump's against war.
Does your dad love the fact
or do you love the fact
that he has been able to make
his opponents say and believe
almost anything as long as
it's in opposition to him?
Like, when he wakes
up in the morning,
that's gotta be the greatest
joy of this whole thing,
is that to get people
who aren't grounded
in anything other
than hating one guy,
you can make them,
well, he can make them believe
anything or say anything.
- Yeah, it's amazing.
The things, you know...
And again, you saw
that with the riots.
I mean, Donald Trump
condemns the riots.
So they support them.
I mean, they're
literally the Democrats,
but again, not one person
mentioned them in the DNC
because if Donald Trump's again,
we have to take exactly the
opposite approach, finally,
Joe Biden, and it
was like you know,
a tepid response at best.
While the rides aren't so good.
He only said that after
Chris Cuomo and Don Lemon
are on CNN saying, "Oh man,
it's starting to affect
us in the poll numbers."
That's the problem
with the Democrats.
You know, they could solve
some of these problems,
but they're not interested in
solving the problems because
if you solve the problem, you
can't campaign on victimhood,
you can't campaign on it.
So finally,
when it's affecting
his polls, you know,
nothing to see here for the
first three months of it.
You know, they were
wonderful, peaceful protests
with buildings, I guess
that spontaneously combusted
in the background, just total
coincidence of course Dave.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- But now it's affecting
him in the polls,
now we gotta come
out against it.
I mean, what kinda
leadership is that?
You know, he came out of
the basement to do this,
to get a clip, to make it seem
like he hasn't been hiding
in the basement, the day
before that he announces, well,
"I'm gonna come out of hiding
in 10 days to address,"
10 days?
Well, is he just hiding
cause he's that incompetent
or is he just not capable of
coming out of the basement?
I mean, obviously they'll
question Trump's health
at every turn, but like
when he's got real issues,
a real history of,
you know, his own dog,
he was not a healthy guy.
I mean, read the chapter
in there you'd say,
"Oh, Jesus Christ."
You think this guy
is gonna be there
at three o'clock in the morning
when something really
goes down and you gotta...
Will he be with it?
You know, are they
giving him something
so that he can appear even a
little bit lucid or coherent,
at times for the few seconds
that they put him on air
and the rest is a disaster,
is he physically not
capable of being out
more than once a week?
Because it sure
looks like it to me,
but no one's gonna question
it, I guess I had to.
- Yeah.
So you mentioned the
peaceful transition of power
that we've had here
for about 240 years.
And that that was really at
risk just three years ago.
Do you think that
they basically,
the Democrats at this point,
are basically setting the stage
to not accept the
results no matter what?
And when I say no matter what
I mean with your dad running?
- Yeah, of course.
I mean, you know,
you saw Hillary say that,
"He should not accept
that no matter what."
I mean, in all fairness, she
hasn't accepted it yet either.
You know, the Democrats, they
talk about all these things.
Remember prior to 16, she said,
"They're not gonna accept it,
they're not gonna accept it,
they're not gonna accept it."
Turns out she didn't accept it.
Turns out they launched an
entire hoax for four years
that the media was a
hundred percent complicit
in pushing for them because
it's their marketing department,
you know, look at Stacey
Abrams in Georgia.
I mean, she still thinks
she's the governor of Georgia.
I mean, the Democrats
have a current history
of not accepting
election results
and pretending that
it didn't happen,
they're doing whatever they
can to try to cheat, steal.
You see the craziness with
some of the mail-in ballots,
they just wanna
blanket that ballots.
I mean, there's elections
that happened three months ago
that they don't even know who
won because they have no idea
five people living
in one apartment
or getting the same ballot.
I mean, it's insane,
but they'll do whatever
they can to win.
They don't care, there's
no principal there anymore.
- So what's the plan then?
Let's go on the assumption
here that your dad wins.
I suspect that he will
and I think he's gonna win
probably by a much larger
margin than most people think.
But if the media and the
Dems won't accept it,
like what's the plan to
kinda get us over this hump,
get us to a place
where even the people
who you disagree with
politically, you know,
that everyone kind of feels
a little more in the fold.
Is there a plan?
Do you think it's even possible?
- I think when he
wins, you know,
and he's not running
for election again,
I think things will normalize.
I do think that,
I think people...
You know, some of that hysteria
will eventually go away
and they'll say, "Fine,
he's got four more years.
We gotta get through it."
In all fairness, he built the
greatest economy America's
ever known.
He's probably the guy
that can do it again.
I think some of
that vitriol ends,
it's not gonna end while
there's an election on going.
And we just gotta, you know,
we gotta make sure we have that.
Staffing up teams and,
you know, poll watchers
and watching for
all of the things
that are gonna be so
flagrant going on.
You know, I mean,
you saw the article
that came out yesterday.
It's like, "Well, Trump's
probably gonna win
on election day but
by the time we count
the crates that show up
that are found constantly
in the back of people's trucks.
Oh, oh, oh, look,
oh, how many are we now by?
5001, okay.
Well magically I found
5,002 ballots here."
A hundred percent of
them are Democrat.
Amazing how this happens.
I mean, it's insane.
So I think that, people have
to be watching out for that.
People have to be
ready for that.
Let's have an open
and honest election.
If you can loot in person,
Dave, you can vote in person,
you know, where there's
absentee systems in place
in some of these States great.
You don't vote that way.
You know, we have no problem
with absentee balloting,
but the conflation of
sort of mail-in in voting
where everyone who's
ever lived at an address
for the last decade, you know,
a magical ballot shows up
in their thing.
You may not live there anymore.
You have no ID to verify it,
and everyone's just
gonna turn them in
and be honest and
ballot harvest that.
I mean, no one
believes that's real.
I mean, look at Jerry Nadler
in New York, you know,
you're a former Congressman.
He's said, how insane
this system is.
I mean, he's on
the record saying,
"Hey, it's right for cheating."
Look at what's going
on in New Jersey.
Look at what went on in some
of the special election stuff,
you know, 60 days out, they
don't even know who won.
They're like, "Oh, we'll
just give it to someone
because why not?"
I mean, it's insanity.
- So with all of that in
mind and election coming
and all the craziness
getting ramped up,
and I will tell
you this my friend,
after you take a month off and
you just suddenly come back
to the craziness in one day,
it all (indistinct) crazier
the day you get back
than doing it every day.
Do you think that your dad...
Let's say your dad wins
and do you think that we
just continue with lockdowns?
We continue with race riots?
All of those things like,
cause they sort of
need it at this point.
Like there's almost
nothing left?
- Well, I think, you know,
the Democrats are gonna
do what Democrats do.
I don't blame Trump you
know that there's riots
in Democrat States,
in Democrat cities,
run by Democrat governors
and Democrat mayors
and Democrats city
councils in some cases
for a hundred years
and it's Trump's fault.
I mean, I don't think
anyone's buying that.
They tried selling it just
like they tried selling it
as peaceful protest for a while.
People were like,
"It's not really.
Oh if it's not
peaceful protesting,
then it's Trump's fault."
I was like, "Well,
what happened?
How do you make that flip?"
But they can, and they will
do it with a straight face.
The reality is, you know,
you see the stuff that came
out of the CDC the other day.
They said, my father
is peddling fake news
cause the CDC put out things
saying that, yeah, you know
listen, 6% of the
Corona virus deaths
that were previously coronavirus
that only 6% of them were
actually coronavirus.
The rest had to
do with, you know,
significant comorbidities
where a big percentage
of those people may have
been dead within the year
with or without Corona.
And so I don't think we
believe in the lockdown.
We've seen the statistics.
It work as effectively as
everyone said it was gonna do,
you know, we tried
that Joe Biden.
Okay, if someone
says to lock down,
I'll just lock down
forever, why not?
We'll lockdown forever
cause guess what?
If your business gets
destroyed, who cares?
You come to us, government
will help you, congratulations.
It's like a drug Dave,
they'll get to hook you on
government handouts forever.
And honestly, that's a winning
strategy for Democrats,
and voting because they
need you to be dependent
on the government,
the second your not,
the second year independent,
the second you're making money.
All of a sudden their
policies aren't that good.
They're not that helpful.
So, that's why they
don't mind the shut down.
That's why they don't mind
that constant lockdown.
That's why, without any science,
you guys like indoor dining,
we're just gonna
shut it down forever.
Like, you know, we'll just...
With another couple
of years why not?
Let's wait for a vaccine.
Well, there may be a vaccine
or, you know, I don't know,
there's no AIDS vaccine yet.
That's been 40 years,
but we're gonna shut down
the economy for 40 years?
It's insanity.
- So what is the role of
the federal government then?
I'm sure you and your dad
have talked about this.
I mean, I know he basically
tried to let the States
do their thing and you
know, my feelings on this,
I think that's the right thing.
But I also get your point, which
is a state like California,
which has a progressive governor
or New York
progressive governor.
They in effect want
to destroy themselves
in essence to take out Trump.
Do you think at some point,
your dad is still the president
of people that live in
New York and California?
Does the federal government
have some responsibility then
to figure out how to
stop that nonsense?
- You know, no different
than the riots.
I mean, we do believe
in states' rights.
We do believe in that sort of
the federalism aspect
of our constitution.
That's why, you know,
when the media runs,
you know, "Trump's a dictator."
I go, "You mean, because
he offered reinforcements
to police agencies
that are being overrun,
but didn't mandate
them to go in?"
I'm trying to say,
I don't know how you
quite come up with this,
but they will.
And no matter what
he does, it's bad.
And so, you know,
I do believe there is
that role for the state
that's important.
That's a big part of what
we fundamentally understand
and agree with that someone
on the ground may know better,
but I think it's more about
the people in those States
recognize it.
I live in New York
city, I see it.
People are fed up.
They think the
Blasio's incompetent,
the people where my
cabin is upstate.
You know, why were we shut down?
There were two cases
in the entire County.
We were shut down
for three months.
We destroyed our business.
We lost, you know, the
summer revenue that we'd get.
People are sick of it.
And so I think it
be a little bit
of a self-regulating
process because you know,
these politicians all have
future aspirations, you know,
and while Cuomo has
been heralded as the
savior of America,
you know, by any medical metric
is 50 out of 50, you know,
50 out of 50 States but,
you know, he's the hero,
a guy like Rhonda Santos
with a larger state,
a more elderly and therefore
susceptible population
has one tenth of the deaths
and he can't do anything right
according to the media.
It's insane.
It's mind blowing.
But again, I think
they've overreached,
the liberal privileges
become so flagrant
that real people
actually see through it.
You know, if they're a
little biased as they've been
for decades, fine,
you give them money.
Okay, fine maybe we
discounted a little bit,
but now you turn on
the TV, be like, yeah,
what I'm seeing is not true.
What I'm seeing is not
true and people get it.
- Do you miss the good liberals
because we talked
about this last time,
but you're a New Yorker.
You grew up mostly
around liberals.
I know you have a lot of
friends that are still liberals.
Like, do you miss
that New York liberal,
that was not sort of
the bananas lefty?
- I do and it's
sort of interesting.
I mean, some of them
are still that way.
And honestly, some of
them are just like,
"I can't believe
what's going on."
I'm like, you know,
the same guys that you
know have for years...
I mean, obviously I'm
such a big gun guy, right?
So the same guys that
for years told me,
why do you need an AR-15?
There's no background check,
You know, Don what
AR-15 should I buy?
Don, oh my God, there's
a waiting period.
What's going on?
I want a gun there's stuff
going on in my neighborhood.
I mean, I go, "For 10 years,
you told me that these
things didn't exist.
Cause you had no idea, but
that was the talking point."
You know,
I think they're waking up to
how ridiculous it's become.
So, you know, it's been a
little bit cathartic for me
because you know, those
radicals that, you know, just,
you literally...
You know, I used to be able
to put myself in their shoes,
argue their point.
It's not like I stick
to a hundred percent
conservative dogma.
You know that in the
conversations we've had
way before we even
got into politics.
I'm pretty open about that.
And yet, you know, I used to
be able to argue those points.
I can't argue the mainstream
Democrat platform anymore
with a straight
face and be like,
"This is somehow
good for America."
Most of them can't and that's
the problem, they see it.
So there's plenty
of those Democrats.
I know a bunch
that are just like,
"Yeah you know,
we don't love every aspect
of what you're doing,
but like we believe in God,
I mean we believe in freedom.
We believe in
freedom of speech."
And you're listing these
things that you know,
I said it to my convention
speech, like, you know,
freedom of speech and thought
that used to be a
liberal value, you know,
tolerance used to
be a liberal value.
I mean, they still run around.
They're the party of
tolerance I'm saying,
try wearing a MAGA hat
in Portland, you know,
try wearing a MAGA hat in
one of these major cities.
Now, if you wore a Biden hat
and I haven't seen any of them,
but if someone
made one and wore--
- (laughs) there's
gotta be one somewhere.
- Yeah, wear it in
the most, you know,
I don't wanna call
it MAGA country.
That's a Jussie
Smollett special.
But like, you know, in
the most conservative...
No one's gonna, they won't
even say anything to you.
They won't spit at you.
They won't throw you, they
won't beat you over the head
with a brick like you're seeing
in these videos, you know,
they won't loot your store,
cancel your business,
or you'll get petitions going
to ruin your life on Facebook.
They won't do that, but
try doing it the other way.
So, you know, the party of
tolerance, isn't so tolerant.
And I think a lot of
reasonable Democrats, you know,
get that.
I also think a lot of,
sort of that history,
that blue-collar working
class, union Democrat,
that had a tradition
of voting that way,
I think they get it too.
They're saying, what is...
I used to hear it at 16.
Well, you know,
"Don if my grandfather
knew that I was voting
for a Republican he'd be
rolling over in his grave."
I go, "Well, what would he say
about today's Democrat platform?
Not that one."
And he goes, "Huh, you
know you're right Don.
Like, oh my God,"
I go, "How many
genders are there?
96 or two, what would he say?"
You know, John F.
Kennedy, you know,
this pillar of the Democrat
party, he'd be all right today,
Dave, he'd be canceled.
Right he'd be me too'ed and
canceled and it would be over.
I mean,
it's just not your grandfather's
Democrat party anymore.
And I think that has
ostracized, you know,
so many former Democrats where
they're starting to become,
you know, either somewhat
conservative, moderate,
or really, you know,
sort of libertarian
in many of their views, which
are so many of my views too.
- Yeah, I hear you, man.
And we've had many
discussions about it.
Let's jump to a private
discussion we had about it.
Cause I think it'll
get to something
really interesting here
which is, my audience
has heard it,
but one night, you and
Kimberly invited David and I
to dinner at Mar-a-Lago.
We had a really nice dinner.
We argued about politics
for two, three hours.
I had a couple of drinks.
You do not drink so I'm not
sure who won the arguments,
but we did about three hours
there and then at the end,
your dad was there
and by the way,
this was right at the
beginning of impeachment.
And everybody said, "The
walls are closing in,
he's freaking out,"
but the guy is sitting
there, he has no tie on.
He was with Giuliani and
some people and he's laughing
and having fun.
Anyway, at the end
of dinner, you said,
"Hey, would you like
to meet my dad?"
And I was like, "Yeah, I'd
like to meet the president.
Let's do it."
And you introduce us and then
he turns to David and he says,
"Well, who are you?"
And David says, "Well,
I'm his husband,"
and your dad immediately,
like there was no pause,
he clapped his hands together,
he slapped them on the table.
He said, "That's great,
that's just great.
I wanna stand up and
shake your hands."
He shakes our hands, he says,
"The only thing wrong with you
guys is you're too handsome.
Melania, can you believe it?
These handsome
guys are married."
And it was just so obvious to me
that in this completely
unscripted, unplanned moment
where you just
brought us up to him,
that he actually said,
I don't know if he
wants me to say it,
but I've said it before.
He said, "I want you
guys to know something.
I don't give a shit and I don't
think anyone's given a shit
in 20 years,"
talking about gay
marriage or whatever.
How do you get over the
labels when it comes
to something like that?
Just the base stuff your dad is,
or your family is homophobic
or they're racist.
Cause no matter how many
times I tell that story,
people say I'm a
sell out somehow
or some version of
some of that stuff.
- The reality is this,
Donald Trump is the first person
to run for president
of the United States,
and when he ran, he
was for gay marriage.
I mean, Obama was against it
because he was told he
had to be against it
and maybe he wasn't in
his actual convictions.
But as part of his
platform, he was against it
because that's what
they had to do, right.
You listen to the talking points
and you must succumb to them.
So, you know, again,
Donald, Trump's
been way ahead of that curve.
I think we have...
We're from New York.
I mean, it's like, (laughs)
a pretty big percentage
of the people around us
at any given time are probably.
We just don't care what
you do in your own bed.
Who gives a shit?
No one's gonna care.
It's one of those
issues you're right.
I mean, we're already
there, frankly,
but in 20 years it'll be
even different, right.
Even more so, I mean,
even some of the older
school people that, you know,
may be a little bit more, you
know, just kinda read the,
sort of the older
religious dogma on it.
Like no one cares.
Even the people that say they
care, no, they don't care.
They sort of, they feel
obligated to do it.
Donald Trump just had
the guts to be like,
"Hey, I don't care.
I'm running for the
Republican nomination.
This is not an issue
for me whatsoever.
Go ahead, have at it."
I always joke that the
best wedding I ever went to
was a gay wedding because
it was on a Tuesday.
They were like, "Well, we don't
wanna screw up your weekend.
We're just gonna have
fun on a Tuesday."
I mean that's perfect.
(laughs)
But this is the
greatest wedding ever.
I don't have to lose
my whole weekend.
That's awesome, I love you guys.
And so, you know, he
has a kid, but again,
you see it every day.
Donald Trump has been so proud.
I think you guys didn't
have a problem with Obama,
literally running against
gay marriage in 2008.
But Donald Trump runs
as a conservative,
literally going
against the, you know,
the more traditional
dogma and again,
I don't think it's a party
platform issue at this point.
Like I said, I don't
think anyone cares,
and they probably
haven't for a while,
but he literally
said, "I don't care."
Well, you know, guess what?
You know, you're a Republican,
you're trying and to
get the evangelical vote
and you still say, "Hey,
I don't care about that."
Let people live and let live.
I mean the Republican party is
the true party of tolerance.
Now that doesn't mean, you know,
I've been open about this too
and it doesn't mean I don't
draw the line some places,
again I don't care
how you even identify.
Where I start to care is when
you know you're six, two,
285 and jacked then you
decide you wanna be a woman
and compete against, you
know, my daughter is sports.
You know identify how you want,
but you start taking her
scholarship, I have a problem.
I wonder where the people who
fought for title nine are,
how come they
won't say anything.
But it's interesting
when I've come out
on some of those
things and again,
I don't give a crap if
you're trans or not,
that makes no difference to me.
It's when you sort of...
Let's have the best.
Let's take a female athlete
who's top of her game,
who's worked her whole life.
I'm a journeyman male athlete.
It's not working out so
well congratulations.
I'm gonna flip it, now
I'm a state champion.
I'm getting your scholarship.
I have a problem with that,
and I've said it I've
been very vocal about it.
I've even put it out on Twitter.
And it's interesting cause
if I put out anything
on Twitter, you know,
before someone could've
even read my tweet,
they're up there with the hate
mail and the hate commentary.
But when I do that one,
it's sort of interesting.
I get this note like, "Damn
it, ah man, God dammit,
I hate him but I'm with
Don Jr. on this one.
But the Democrat party doesn't
have the sense to stand up
and say enough is enough.
Identify how you want it
but let's not start destroying
opportunities for females.
And like I said, where are all
the feminists on this issue?
I mean, it's basic biology.
- This should be their
biggest issue, yeah.
- But they won't.
- This should be
the biggest issue.
- So that's why it's
important for Trump
to be able to
acknowledge these things,
to be able to combat it,
to not just blindly
follow the dogma,
but with the left today,
you have to be woke.
And if you're not woke enough
that by itself is
now cancelable Dave.
You get canceled
for not being woke,
but again, it's not like
the goalposts are fixed.
The goalposts move
ever and ever,
like you can wake up one day.
You were woke yesterday,
by today you're all right.
You haven't kept up with the
latest bat shit crazy concept,
you know that they're
jamming down your throats
as a narrative and if you
don't get there, you're out.
You know, you might as well
be full fledged conservative.
Even if you're 99% liberal.
- Do you see a reason for that?
I mean, I've been
saying for a while now
that the fundamental
reason for that
is that basically if
you're on the right,
if you're a conservative
that you believe in
individual rights,
that's the number one thing.
You believe that everyone
should be treated equally
under the law.
It doesn't mean you act
like it all the time,
but that's sort of the
fundamental principle.
I can't figure out what the
fundamental principle is
of the left anymore,
other than government.
And that is an ever
moving goalpost.
- It is.
And I can't either, like I
said, I literally can't keep up.
By the time we get
done with this talk,
I can look on my Twitter
feed and be like, wow,
like new outrage cycle,
probably three or four of them,
like things that at any other
point in time in history,
wouldn't be even
remotely outrageous,
let alone contentious.
But it's like it's a race,
who can outwoke themselves
to the point where
it's become a parity.
I mean, it's a shame
because it doesn't mean
there's not issues in the world
that we don't have to address.
But when you scream panic,
when you're screaming fire
in a crowded theater, every
time there's something
and everyone
mobilizes immediately,
where's the problem.
You desensitize
people to real issues.
I mean, racism, one
of those things,
I call it sort of the
easy button of the left.
You know, if I can't
win an argument,
if I don't have
facts to back me up,
if I don't have statistics,
racist obviously.
I mean, we weren't talking--
- What does your dad do?
What does your dad do to
combat the fact that it works?
It doesn't matter
if he's on stage
during the State
of the Union saying
black unemployment
is all time low
and the Congressional Black
Caucus sits there like this,
I thought they would
maybe applaud that
or be happy about that.
But what do you do to just
combat the horrific way
that that nonsense sticks?
- I think honestly, you
just gotta keep fighting it.
You got to keep winning.
You know, I don't
think there's a chance
that in any time soon,
the media is gonna
become unbiased.
I don't think you do that.
I think you have to
just keep winning.
You have to put up the numbers,
you have to make sure
that a reasonable amount
of the people see that.
And I think they do.
I think if you
look at our numbers
within the African American
community right now
and that they get it,
they see what's going,
they don't want violence
in their streets.
You know, they're
watching the media
as their businesses
are burning down.
You know, many of these
businesses are minority owned.
They're burning down and no
one's looking to help them.
They're looking to get
them a picture of it
as though this is
somehow Trump's fault.
But I think they see through it,
you know, it's harder to
get through, you know,
those levels, especially in
the big and inner cities,
because there's such
a stranglehold by
the Democrat party,
within those cities that
they get the information
to disseminate down
to the voter is hard.
You're going through so
many levels of filters,
but I always say like, you know,
if Joe Biden knew how to
fix racial issues, you know,
why didn't he do it by now?
I mean, he had 50 years,
he was vice president for
eight years under Obama,
the first African
American president.
Like if you really
wanted to fix it,
you could have focused
on opportunity zones.
You could have even tried.
They had the House
and the Senate.
They didn't even attempt it
because they need
you to be a victim.
They need to be able to come
back to you every four years.
You're a victim.
So why didn't you fix it
in your half a century Joe?
Is anyone dumb enough to believe
that he's gonna
somehow fix it now?
- Yeah.
Well, speaking of fixing
stuff, people kind of forget
because you're thought of
now as a political guy,
although that really is
not what you truly are,
at least at the
day to day level,
you're running Trump
properties and Trump hotels
and all that stuff.
We spoke a little bit
right at the beginning
of the lockdown.
And you were freaking out
about what was happening
to the economy and
employees that you had had.
I think you told me there
was a guy that you had had
for like 35 years that you
were gonna have to temporarily
furlough or something like
a whole bunch of stuff.
Where are you guys at
business wise right now?
What's going on with
just hotel business
and the other stuff
that you care about
and spend most of your
day talking about?
- Yeah listen, that's not easy.
The hotel business, you know,
people aren't traveling,
the cities are locked down.
You can't have dining,
you gotta wear masks.
I mean, you know,
it's not a great time
to be in the hotel business now,
you know, for better or worse.
Unlike Hunter Biden,
we used to be international
business people too.
We stopped doing new
international deals
when my father took office
to avoid even the
notion of impropriety.
Now, Hunter Biden became
an international business
miraculously became an
international businessman
when his father took the VP.
So we're doing the best
we can with some of our,
you know, the clubs
and stuff like that.
People are actually good,
they wanna get outside.
Their golf clubs are doing well.
Hotels is a rough
business right now,
but we gotta fight through that,
we gotta build back the economy.
But I think that's what's
important about Trump.
He's the guy that
did it once before.
He's the guy that despite like
probably more incoming fire
than any president
in modern history
built the greatest
economy we've ever known,
created the lowest
employment numbers,
cut the red tape and the
bureaucracy, cut taxes
so that business is
gonna employ more people.
Wages were going up for
the lowest income earners.
Like he's the guy
that can do it again
coming out of this crisis.
Coming out of a global
pandemic caused by China.
Now Joe Biden, when Donald Trump
shutdown travel from China,
Joe Biden called him a racist.
I mean, at what point
in history, Dave
would shutting down,
travel from the epicenter
of a deadly viral outbreak
be anything other
than common sense.
Was it racist when we
did it from Europe too?
No, but that allowed us
to slow down the spread
and allowed us to create,
you know, ventilators,
public, private
partnerships to do that,
get the PPD and the hospitals.
I mean, it's a virus.
It's not like you can stop it,
but they would have left the
country open for a month,
overwhelmed our systems,
you know, but again,
that liberal privilege
allows you to basically
not have a solution say
that Trump did it all wrong,
despite the facts,
despite the positions that
they were taking at the time.
And it's like a big win and
the media cheers them on
as though he did
something competent
and they clearly won't
talk about Joe Biden
and the Obama Administration's
response to swine flu
in 2009.
Luckily that wasn't as
deadly as this, thank God.
But literally tens of
thousands of people had it
before they did anything.
Then they didn't
replenish their stocks.
Joe Biden had a similar role
to Mike Pence, you know,
back in 2009 on this
and his own guy.
His guy said, "Man, we got
lucky this thing wasn't deadly
cause we literally
did everything wrong."
It's in the book.
I mean, I do a
chapter on that one
conveniently because it was
the Obama Administration,
they were infallible.
They could do nothing
wrong even when
they had glaring error.
So people won't hear that.
They need to see the corollary
before they're sold this notion
that Joe Biden would have
somehow done it so much better.
They had their chance,
they blew that too.
- All right, well, we've
done about 49 minutes,
according to that
clock right there
and we haven't
talked about big tech
and I would say maybe
more than anybody,
you're in the center
of the big tech fight.
- I am.
- As most of my audience
knows you now have a community
on Locals which is the
tech company I started
and you own it, you control it.
You can do whatever
you want with it.
And every time you get
booted off Twitter,
you can put your stuff on Local.
So you're safe and your
audience can find you.
But do you think that perhaps
the biggest liberal privilege
that exists is the privilege
to be able to say what you want
on big tech platforms
and not be suspended,
while a guy like you
or plenty of other,
just right leaning people.
We're not talking
about alt-right racist,
and we're not talking about
people that are threatening
to murder people
are gonna get the boots.
- A hundred percent.
I mean, you know, I've been
vocal about this for years.
I've been thrown off
every platform imaginable,
again not for pushing anything
crazy, but for pushing basic,
you know, conservative
thought, you know,
you talk about the alt-right?
I'm not defending them in
any way, shape or form,
but there's an alt-left.
There's a super radical left,
a hate-filled organization.
Whether it's Hezbollah, whether
it's the Ayatollah talking.
I mean just yesterday,
antisemitic tropes on Twitter.
Well that doesn't violate
community guidelines,
Twitter a few weeks ago, China
putting out this information.
I mean, they acknowledged
these are Chinese
government officials
disseminating Coronavirus
disinformation on Twitter
does not violate their
community standards.
But me putting up a tweet
about a couple of doctors
treating patients with
hydroxychloroquine in the field,
medical doctors doing
it, seeing real results.
I say, wow, this is great.
I didn't even say,
"Hey, this is fact,"
I said, interesting
cause it's very different
than the narrative
we've been spoonfed.
I get thrown off Twitter.
- Yeah.
That was, the one that
booted you off Twitter
right before I left, yeah.
- Yeah, you know I got
in trouble with Instagram
back in the day when I
called out Jusse Smollett.
And I just said, I don't know,
like if this happened
in America, you know,
fry those bastards, that
shit does not fly here.
But has anyone like, you
know, looked into the story
because you know, I see
Ellen and every today show
and oh my God, it was
their dream come true.
You know, white supremacists
wearing MAGA hats in Chicago.
Like I go, you think
they would have lasted
more than 10 or 12 seconds
without getting shot?
Like do you think these guys
knew who Jussie Smollett is?
Cause I don't know.
I don't know many
white supremacists
and I don't think I know any
and I wouldn't associate with
them if I knew they were,
but I have a feeling they're
not watching "Empire".
I mean, I just don't
think, you know,
I don't think it's
a show for them.
Like if you're a
white supremacist,
you're probably not
watching "Empire".
You probably don't assume
that this really rich actor
is gonna go get
subway at 2:00 AM
on the coldest
night of the year.
You know, I've been all over--
- And then leave the news.
He left the news on
for a couple of hours.
- The little shoestring
news he was like twine.
I'm like, I don't know.
If the guy's a decent actor
maybe I haven't seen the show
but like, he's
not a good writer,
but I was the only
person in America
let's call it with a following,
with something to lose.
That was like, okay, screw this.
Like I'm all in because
this has to be bullshit.
Now, if I was wrong,
I'm over right.
It's Canon, I'm
canceled forever.
But I got Donald Trump
Jr. spreading hate.
He's an anti this he's oh
a terrible human being.
Well turns out I was right.
Turns out I was right.
You know, no one questioned
it because it was so good
they had to push it.
So, to get thrown off platforms,
the most vile
people on the left,
whether that's pornographic,
whether that's this,
whether it's, you
know, antisemitic,
not one has ever been
thrown off Twitter,
not one has ever taken
their content down.
Not one gets fact-checked
like Joe Biden in the
Pennsylvania stuff.
It's one sided,
you've never heard
of one of those instances, deep
platforming, demonetization.
And so it's a real threat.
They are heavily
putting their foot
on the scale of this election.
It's literally,
like I said earlier,
it's why I made my book
available at DonJr.com
rather than just on Amazon or
any of the other platforms,
you can get them there if you
want the one-click shopping.
But like a lot of
our guys were like,
"I just don't wanna
give it to Amazon.
I just don't wanna do it."
I was like, "All right, here's
another option for you."
And like I said, I'm moving
like a really big amount
of volume just on my
own little website
because they don't
want to go to Amazon
because they see, you know,
what's going on with big tech.
Now Amazon, I don't think
they've done anything
with me on that one.
It's Twitter,
Facebook, Instagram,
you know, they play
much more games.
I don't know that they're
playing games will be on Amazon.
I didn't notice it
the last time around,
but people don't
wanna support that.
And when we need to
create an environment,
people have said, "Well
start conservative Twitter."
I was like, "I don't
really wanna do that either
because I actually
wanna have the argument,
may the best idea win,"
I mean, that's a concept that
goes deep in American history.
They don't even wanna
hear the corollary.
They're gonna spoonfeed
you a narrative.
That is the
narrative, that is it.
You cannot question it.
You're not allowed to touch
it, if you do, you're canceled,
then you're over.
That's really scary for
the future of our country
and for the next generation.
- So what do you want
to happen with big tech?
I mean, we see, you
know, every few months
we tried out Zuckerberg and
we tried out Jack from Twitter
and the rest of them.
And they, you know, say what
either may or may not be true
or get caught in half
lies or everything else.
And then, you know,
your dad did roll back
some of their protections
with section 230
of the Communications Act.
But what do you actually
think is the right thing?
And do you think it's kinda too
late relative to an election
that's gonna happen
in about two months?
- It will be for this election
and you know, they've been
putting their foot on the scale
for the last four years.
They've been pushing the
Russia disinformation,
you know, that inboxing
as a big issue, you know,
cause that's not just
social media, right?
That's, you know,
information, you know,
if you sign up for five
Democrat congresspeople
that are running for
Congress right now
and sign up for five
Republicans, check
your junk mail,
which ones are going
to your junk mail
and which ones are ending
up at the top of your inbox.
I mean Google and
all those places
they're doing that
kinda stuff too.
They're really, you know,
putting it on there,
but the big problem
that we've always faced
and that you and I, I know
we've had this conversation
is that a lot of conservatives
don't even understand the issue.
You know, you had an old
conservative Senator,
he's got a 25-year-old running
it, social media has no idea.
He doesn't see it.
You know, when I hit send,
I know what it's gonna do
until the algorithm kicks
in and screws with me.
I know within a couple of likes,
how many retweets that one's
gonna get versus this one,
I'll be like, "I'll send
this one, it's not great,
but it'll do okay.
This one's gonna go big.
You know, I know and I've
seen it go 2000, 3000, 4000.
Stop.
It's over, you know, the
algorithm catches it,
and sensors it.
The problem is for so long,
so many Republicans don't even
realize that it's an issue.
They don't realize it's a
top issue with their base
who just want that
freedom of speech.
You know, if you're pro-life,
if you're pro second
amendment, if you're religious,
I mean, your accounts
get scrutinized,
you know, screwed with much
more than anything else.
And so a big part of
what I've tried to do
is wake up conservatives.
They do this whole
well it's free market.
No, it's not.
It's not free market
when you're getting
billions of dollars
in liability protections
from the federal government,
and you're acting as a publisher
deciding who is gonna magically
show up in a Google search.
I mean, look at Breitbart.
You can't even find Breitbart
on Google, it will not...
But if you issue do something...
Buzzfeed, all the
left-wing rags,
they'll show up as though
that is the gospel.
You don't even have that
access to the information
unless you literally
know that URL
that you're looking to find
and so that affects it.
So we gotta stop
going with this notion
that it's free market.
We have to wake up
conservatives to understand
what's actually going on a
bunch more guys are doing that.
I mean, you know, Josh
Holly's done a pretty good job
in the Senate with that.
Kevin McCarthy in the House,
but we got to get everyone
else on board and push for it
because there is a
point where, you know,
they're gonna have more power
than anyone in government
in terms of the ability
to shape hearts and minds
with misinformation or otherwise
and they're already doing it.
- Yeah all right, Jr.
I got one more for ya.
Do...
Well no, I'm gonna ask
it in a different way.
I was gonna say, do
you think your dad's
gonna win the election?
I'm not gonna say that,
I know you think that.
Play out the rest
of the year for me,
just play out what you
think the next two months
will be like, election day.
And then what
happens in January?
- Well, listen, you know, next
couple months will be brutal.
You know, we're gonna work.
Joe is gonna go
from his basement
and the media is gonna pretend
that he's doing something.
You know, I think we'll
be able to, you know,
paint that picture for
the American public,
like the RNC did you know
without those incredible
images and stories
versus the DNC.
I think we'll
continue to do that.
I think you see that,
you know, the Democrats are
just staffing up legal teams.
I mean, they haven't bothered
to try to create a ground game
cause they know
there's no enthusiasm.
So what they're doing is
staffing up legal teams
to try to game it out later on.
So I see that being the case,
which is why so many
people have to mobilize,
get your friends out, make
sure they vote, you know,
don't sit on the sidelines
cause honestly, it might be,
we have to win
overwhelmingly, you know,
to get over that hump of the
games that will be played
on the other side and I think
if we do that, you know,
a lot of that fire goes away
because once they're
sort of stuck with Trump
for another four years, you
know, they'll deal with it.
They'll move on, they'll
start their battle for 2024
and about November 4th,
COVID will magically not be
the talking point
that it has been
because you know,
once it's over,
you don't need that fear
over people anymore.
We can get back to
living our lives
a little bit more normal.
Doesn't mean we won't
still have to deal
with it a little bit,
but I imagine it's
gonna be very different
and you'll give Donald
Trump another four years
to build back that economy
and then some focus on things
that he's a builder
first and foremost,
you said that earlier.
I mean, let's do some
infrastructure for America
rather than building
roads, tunnels and bridges
in Afghanistan that
blow up the next day.
Let's do that here, let's
bring our troops home.
Let's put them to work here.
Let's create
infrastructure for America,
put Americans back to work.
I mean, that would be
Donald Trump's wheelhouse.
And I think, once you get
through an election cycle,
you'll see Democrats and the
Nancy Pelosi's of the world,
maybe finally willing
to actually try to help
rather than try to
be a hindrance at
every step of the way,
cause once they're stuck
with them for the last thing,
he's not up for reelection
anymore, you know,
hopefully you
infuse some normalcy
back into political discourse.
- I didn't know,
you're a dreamer.
I can't believe it.
(laughs)
- Hey everyone's
got to have hopes.
- All right.
The book is "Liberal Privilege"
by New York times
bestselling author, Don Jr.
Don, thanks for doing the show.
If you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlists,
all right, over here,
and to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.